oh how is it going guys
little talk today about a recent
computer that I put Linux on and coffee
time Cheers oh that's hot
that's real hot well Smith me apply ok
so I recently got this Linux this
computer input Linux on it
it came with Windows so as some of you
might know I did a video a couple videos
back about how to install Linux and I'm
gonna installed on this computer but I
didn't have a dongle so what we have
here is an hazers Zenbook and sorry for
the poor lighting in camera it's just
I'm working with what I got right now so
please consider liking subscribing maybe
even supporting on patreon if you want
to see higher quality content as I'll be
improving in the future as I go but what
we have here is a computer that is a I
want to say the model number but it's so
tiny on here that I can barely see it
and this lighting is not actually
helping ok
write this down there's a a zu s--
Zenbook ux302 ok so it's one of their
little fancier nicer models small screen
and it came with windows on it also does
this does this sort of thing flip it
over so this came with Windows 10 when I
first booted it up I had to go get
drivers for Windows for this it wasn't
properly install apparently and
everything was just glitchy and I
thought I had a lemon of a computer I
can't you know it like I caught this in
a USB dongle it's a pretty cheap one but
it just started glitch in hell now this
computer is all a USB see I know I'm
really scattered in this order I didn't
pro play
I just started recording so only USBC on
this thing so I had to get a USBC dongle
and then hey I can mess with it more so
I did that
got a little wireless mouse too over
here and you know on Windows it was just
glitching out it was just kept saying
device not recognized etcetera etcetera
so it was like whatever okay well at
least I gotta I'm gonna just mess around
and see if I can get legs on there so I
took my little MX Linux USB for a couple
videos ago and plug this thing in and lo
and behold it just installed like
nothing it was very easy I did have to
go to the bios of course which I think
was f2 or I don't remember I think it
was f2 on this computer or escape one of
those and I did have to turn safe boot
off you know after I installed but
during the install I didn't really have
to do a whole lot it was already
configured in a way that just took it
makes Linux all I had to do was pop in
the USB Drive and go through the install
and I just wiped Windows because it was
not working right anyway so what's the
point you know there were a few other
weird glitches going on they were just
you know it wasn't even a useable
computer with Windows on it basically
and I would have had to done I've done
either a reinstall windows or
troubleshoot for days messing with who
knows what
so Linux just seemed like a fun option
and it has been a really fun option
everything works well flawlessly on here
including this dongle no errors it just
it works it's a recognized device and it
is working with the USBC now so I was
able to just get all the packages I
wanted to installed on the MX Linux here
to do the development I want and that's
all going pretty fine what I was really
looking for was any functional type of
bugs or anything like that cuz I'd
always annoys me I want to get some new
laptop or computer and put Linux on it
and then it just doesn't something that
comes with a laptop just doesn't
function like maybe the back like
keyboard or the trackpad or or the touch
screen like something just doesn't
right and that's always frustrating that
didn't happen everything works great
all these hotkeys appear seem to work
fine the keyboard brightness hotkeys
work the keyboard illuminates from
complete you can turn completely off to
as bright as it gets
same with the screen all that works here
just fine on the Zen book soft highly
recommend the Zen book for Linux
computer if you just want a mobile Linux
computer and don't want to pay 2 grand
for a pine book with you know or
whatever I don't even know but yeah all
these keys seem to work fine we have
volume controls we got a power button
and I really don't have any complaints
it even it even does the flippy thing
just fine I don't know if it rotates
let's see if it rotates know so it
doesn't auto rotate that's one thing
they're missing
maybe there's something like installed
fix that but I believe with this model
it supposed to I don't on that actually
because when you flip it oh wait yeah
it's supposed to you can hold it like
like so and I should rotate so that's
like the only thing that doesn't really
function but if the backlight keyboard
is working and all the mouse toast
working fine actually I really love
their mouse support they have a the next
Linux has like I'm Mouse and touchpad
Center and they you can configure every
different playing device and I found
that to be very nice when getting this
thing set up oh I like it
so yeah I guess that's it in my
experience with this computer Lennox has
been better than Windows pretty
significantly so really considering I
couldn't even use the computer with
Windows with it's odd glitches and it
not recognizing hardware and I don't
know if that's Windows fault or if it
was the install but hardware wise
everything seems perfect on this
computer so it was definitely a software
glitch and legs just kind of confirmed
with
well thanks for watching my video hope
you enjoyed this video and we've come
down below let me know what computer you
got for Linux and how that's working out
for you but this is in book UX 370 you
is I love it
with MX limit my neck speed up guys